hi there today i'm going to do a little
slightly different type of video
you know we're all not all but a lot of
people myself included are in isolation
locked down or encouraged to not guard
unless we have to and particularly if
you're my age group
and it's a little bit discouraging and
depressing to see the news about the
number of people who are being
hospitalized and the problems at the
hospitals and the number of people who
are dying
and the impact on our economies and so
forth but
what i want to talk about today is
connectedness solidarity
so
recognizing that people are a lot of
people are now sort of isolated we
started our live streams a link where we
encourage people to come and participate
in a live stream we encourage
er link users
to come and participate and share their
experiences
i've been doing a lot of interviews with
other youtubers in different languages
you'll see more and more of those
but today i thought i would do more of a
conventional video and talk about
you know here we are in isolation but
ultimately we are connected all right
the world has always been connected now
sometimes you you hear people say now
well you know this is going to change
how we operate
certainly we've seen countries close
their borders uh
there's talk about countries wanting to
become more self-sufficient in in their
economies and stuff and i don't think
that's going to last very long i think
ultimately we will get back to
uh interconnected world with some
modification i think for a while people
may travel less
but then again after the spanish flu of
1918 1919
people started traveling again and in
those days travel uh essentially meant
getting on a boat and
we've seen how boats large boats
cruising uh ships can be major
incubators for
various forms of influenza like the
kovid
influenza and yet still people started
traveling again so you know the
perspective will change as we start to
come out of it
and hopefully um with more and more
people wearing masks so that we don't
spread it as much with more testing to
find out who has had it who hasn't both
the sort of diagnostic testing and the
the antibody testing there'll be new
technology there will be some treatment
right now there seem to be very
dependent on these ventilators that
don't have a very high success rate once
the person is in really bad shape and i
think there will be better treatments
um
testing treatment tracking they have to
get better at following people you know
who are perhaps identified with a
cluster and everyone they were in
contact with all of these things how we
treat them in hospitals our testing
ability our tracking ability our ability
to slow down transmission
we're learning more and more and so we
will get we've only get better at these
things so uh to me it's just a matter of
slowly the
present lockdown will start to get
removed so the key thing is what are we
going to do now so to me it's a great
opportunity to work on your language
skills you're not surprised to have me
say that uh because we are connected you
know and and uh like in my persian i'm
reading about the history of iran and
obviously the persians were connected to
the turks and
byzantine empire and
you know italian
merchants from genoa and
and even you know the vikings around
that time i mean the world has always
been interconnected you know explorers
from indonesia who traveled to
madagascar i mean
the world has always been connected and
this connection is has been accelerating
and will continue to accelerate and and
i think what we're adding now is sort of
this virtual level of connection which
is also accelerating and probably will
one of will be one of the sort of
lasting impacts of everybody now forced
to you know connect virtually work
virtually and so forth so
yeah learn languages all of this
interconnection and i should add
solidarity because we're only going to
get through this thing if we all work
together you know the development of
testing first of all the experience of
different countries and how they you
know some have been hit worse than
others but there's experience there
that's all being shared um the testing
of potential therapeutic you know
treatments or drugs all of that is being
shared they're testing all of those i
can't remember their names i mean
there's this
hydro
chloroquinine or something i i can't
remember and then there's some other a
former ebola drug there's like five or
six of these and there are tests going
on everywhere in every province in
canada in
different states in the u.s in germany
china
uh you name it uh everywhere
and everything that people are and this
race to find a vaccine
and to find faster and better ways of
testing this is all being done in every
corner of the world people are sharing
that information
so this the solidarity the recognition
that we're in the same boat together
uh that's gonna get us out of this so i
don't think once we come out of it that
we will revert back to sort of
self-sufficient economies there will be
increasing interchange so
learn languages
and
because we can't expect that this
international solidarity connectedness
exchange is always going to just happen
in english
english speakers in fact miss out
because they miss out on the fun unless
they are
as i assume many of you who are
listening to me and who are english
speakers you're into learning languages
and you realize just how much
of a reward we get from
learning them and then having learned
them
and so increasingly i think that that
we're going to see increasing
interconnectedness
not necessarily as much you know
flying off somewhere at the drop of a
hat
which isn't necessarily a bad thing
either
and uh so i think one of the things that
we can sort of devote ourselves to
in this period of you know
grim news followed by grim news
is to come up
come out of this with something a
breakthrough
in
one or more languages so that's
certainly my approach i'm working on my
arabic and persian it's a long road
without a doubt
but i was reviewing some of my
conversation reports with my link tutors
and it's amazing how much i've learned
even though i you know very often you
don't feel like you're learning anything
but in the end you are and i'm in no
great hurry
persia has been around for a long time
the uh
our arabic language has been around for
a long time any other language like
turkish that i want to learn later on
it's also been around for a long time
it's not going anywhere however long i
take to learn it is just fine with me
and maybe
after that i'll learn some other
language and explore different parts of
the world because we are all connected
and that's kind of what i wanted to say
today thank you for listening bye for
now